CARLA NAUMBURG: My
name is Carla Naumburg.
I'm a clinical social
worker, and a writer,
and a mother of two young kids.
And I wrote this book called
"Parenting in the Present
Moment."
So today we're going
to talk a little bit
about mindful parenting.
And the plan is that I'm going
to talk for 30 to 40 minutes,
and then I'd love to
answer any questions.
And we can have a discussion
about some of the stuff I've
written in the book.
I believe there's another
talk happening in this room
when I'm done.
So if you'd like me
to sign your book,
I think there's some
books for sale down there.
And then we can go
outside, and I'm
happy to sign it just to let
the next talk come on in.
So whenever I start
talking about parenting,
my favorite thing to talk
about, and think about, and do
is sleep.
So I always start with a
little passage about sleep
from the book.
I'm going to do a little
reading from the book
today and a little talking.
"So I'm lucky enough to
be a fairly good sleeper,
or at least I was
before I had kids,
which is fortunate, because
I need a lot of sleep
to function.
One or two nights without
my full eight hours and I
become a grumpy, dysfunctional
red hot button just asking
to be pushed.
I knew this about myself long
before I became a mother,
and I was terrified
about what was
going to happen to me once
my first child was born.
It's not surprising, then,
that I spend most of my first
pregnancy obsessed with sleep,
not just my own but also
my baby's.
Sleep is the panacea of
parenthood, the altar at which
all exhausted parents worship.
And I must have read
seven or eight books
about how to get a baby to
sleep through the night, four
words that became my constant
prayer through the first weeks
of my daughter's life
before I even gave birth.
So every sleep expert has
different advice, of course,
but one thing became
abundantly clear to me,
I had to figure out how
to get this kid to sleep.
By the time our
daughter was born,
my husband and I
had acquired a crib
without a drop side, of
course, a firm mattress that
fit precisely in
the crib to avoid
the risk of the
baby getting stuck
between the mattress
and the bars,
a co-sleeper for
next to our bed,
a pack and play for traveling,
a vibrating bouncy chair for nap
time, a swing in case the baby
didn't like the bouncy chair,
a standing fan for her bedroom--
we'd read an article somewhere
that those reduce
the risk of SIDS--
a white noise machine
in case the fan wasn't
loud enough, light blocking
shades for the windows,
a space heater so
we could perfectly
regulate the
temperature of her room,
a baby monitor, and special
sleep sacks that should
be used instead of blankets.
We congratulated ourselves
on not succumbing
to the video monitor.
We weren't going to
be those parents.
By the time my
daughter was born,
I was an expert in
sleep training and sleep
safety who had never
actually put a baby to sleep.
And I had all the knowledge
and gear to prove it.
The first few weeks
of life with a newborn
were rough to be sure,
with long, exhausting days
and hourly wakings every night.
But when she was six
weeks old, our daughter
slept through the night.
Eight hours of uninterrupted
slumber filled bliss.
It was heavenly.
It was lifesaving, and it
had nothing to do with me
and all of my obsessive
reading and buying.
As I would come to learn
over the next weeks, months,
and years, my
daughter is a sleeper.
She's a shockingly picky
eater and potty training
was no walk in the park.
But that kid can sleep."
So I always start out
talking about this,
because I think my
approach to sleep really
characterized my first
couple of years as a mother.
I was constantly researching
and thinking about
and worrying about every
possible thing that
could happen to my
child or my family
and then deciding I needed
to understand it and fix it.
And this was all
before I even knew
it was going to be a problem
for us, so spending all my time
sort of running around,
putting out fires
before they were even burning.
And a part of this is
because of who I am.
I'm an anxious person.
I like to be on top of things.
I like to have information
and solve problems.
Part of this, I think,
is a natural outcome
of being a parent in
the age of social media
and constant information.
Because every day there's a
new article on the "Huffington
Post" about the latest study,
about the latest thing that's
going to screw up your kid if
you don't fix it right away.
And I bought into all of
it hook, line, and sinker.
The thing about trying to
solve every problem even
if it's not actually a problem
is that you get worn out.
And you get exhausted.
And you get overwhelmed.
And you get stressed out.
And all those things
happened to me.
And so I took it out on my kids.
Why?
Well, because honestly they were
the people I was with the most.
And if we're also going
to be really honest,
little kids as adorable,
and lovely, and sweet
as they can be, are
super annoying sometimes.
Even when they're doing
the developmental stuff
they're supposed to
be doing, it's hard.
Any parent can tell you this.
So what happened was I
started yelling at them.
Now, I wasn't much of a yeller
before I became a mother.
But the stress was too much,
and I was taking it out on them.
Now, I knew that I
wasn't alone in this.
Our parenting generation,
we're a bunch of yellers.
I remember really understanding
this the first time
when I read an article
in "The New York Times"
a couple years ago
that said, we are
generation of devoted parents.
We buy the organic food, and
we get them the perfectly
carved wooden little blocks.
And we make sure we're
at their soccer games.
And we do all this stuff.
We're constantly praising them.
We're so devoted to them.
But man, we yell at them.
And so I read this article.
It made me feel a little bit
better that I wasn't alone.
I wasn't the only one.
But I also knew how I felt when
I lost my temper with my kids.
And I saw how it
was impacting them.
And I knew it wasn't good
for our relationship.
So I decided that I needed
to put a stop to it.
And I remember
when that happened.
It was one night.
It was a really bad night.
I had blown up at them,
and I finally just put them
in front of the TV.
I thought, you
know, them watching
TV is much better than
me yelling at them.
And then I sort of
silently berated myself
for being that parent
who couldn't parent
as well as a TV could.
And then I sat down at
Google-- yes, Google--
typed into the search bar, "How
do I stop yelling at my kids?"
Literally, I typed those words.
Now here I am, a social worker.
I have devoted my entire
professional career
to understanding people,
and human development,
and relationships, and how
to manage our emotions,
and how to recognize them,
and what to do with them when
they become overwhelming.
And in that moment, in
the fog, and fatigue,
and exhaustion of
parenthood, I literally
couldn't solve this problem.
So I turned to Google.
And there were thousands of
articles, and lists, and blog
posts, and suggestions
about what to do
when you want to stop yelling.
And some of them
were really good.
Take a few deep breaths.
Do some jumping jacks.
Go for a walk around the block.
My favorite one--
scream into the toilet.
I remember reading that
one and being like,
I deal with poop all day
long, and you want me
to go scream into the toilet?
No.
But nonetheless, I made my own
little list of suggestions,
hung it on the wall, and
decided I'm going to do this.
I'm not going to
yell at my kids.
I'm going to take
my deep breaths.
I'm going to stretch,
whatever it is.
Well, you all know how
this turned out, right?
Within a day or two,
I lost it with them.
I felt horrible.
By the time I remembered to do
my little list, it was done.
I already had my mommy tantrum.
It's pretty frustrating.
But, you know, I'm stubborn.
I wasn't going to give up.
But this time I decide
I'm going to turn
to the academic literature.
I'm an academic.
I understand how
this stuff works.
When I need real
answers, I'm going
to turn to the
heavy-hitters, and I
know I can think my way
out of this problem.
So I start reading all
these studies related
to parent behavior and child
discipline, all this stuff,
whatever.
And at the bottom of
every single one of them--
you know how they always
have that section that
says "suggestions
for future research"?
They all said something
along the lines of,
this parent could probably
benefit from mindfulness
and meditation.
So I want to read
you a short passage
from the book about just
how I felt about that idea.
"There was no way I was going
to meditate-- absolutely not.
I tried meditation once before
in college in hopes of scoring
an easy PE credit
required for graduation.
I will never forget
sitting on that hardwood
floor in the middle
of a stinky gymnasium.
A tall, thin man dressed all in
white with a long wispy beard
instructed us to cross
our legs, close our eyes,
breathe deeply, and
clear our minds.
I crossed my legs, and it
all went downhill from there.
Clear my mind?
What did that mean?
I didn't really understand how
I was supposed to clear my mind,
so I decided to
think about black.
Because black-- there's
nothing in black.
So if you think about black,
clearly your mind is clear.
But then I thought about it.
You know, I visualized black.
But then I thought, well, black
isn't really my favorite color.
I like blue a lot better.
But I can't decide if I
like turquoise or sapphire,
and the next thing I knew, my
mind was anything but clear.
And then within minutes,
all I could think about
was how much my butt
hurt and my nose itched.
So in my mind, meditation
was for hippies
who didn't have
their shit together.
And mindfulness was just a
fancy word for reformed hippies
who barely had
their shit together.
I was happy to spend
an hour each week
in the confines of
the therapy office,
but meditation was an entirely
different proposition.
It was just one step
away from shaving my head
and handing out
flowers at the airport.
I was a type-A, take control,
get things done kind of girl,
and there was no way I was going
to spend my precious parenting
time chanting and
lighting incense sticks."
So as you can tell, I had a lot
judgments and misconceptions
about mindfulness
and meditation.
And I was just not educated.
I had no idea.
But the thing is, it
wasn't getting better.
I didn't know how to
change the problem.
I didn't know what to do.
And these ideas kept sort
of popping up in my life.
People were
suggesting them to me.
And finally, I
thought, all right.
I'm going to figure out
what this is all about.
So I signed up for an eight-week
mindfulness-based stress
reduction course,
also called MBSR.
I'm sure many of you
have heard of it.
This is a curriculum
that was originally
developed by Jon Kabat-Zinn
in the late 1970s.
He was working at the
University of Massachusetts
out in Worcester, Mass.
And it's an exploration of
mindfulness, and meditation,
and basic yoga.
And when Jon Kabat-Zinn
created this,
he did two really
brilliant things.
He's really a
pioneer in bringing
all of these practices and
all this wisdom to the West.
The first thing he
did was he really
stripped it of any religious or
spiritual background, language.
He took all that stuff out.
Because he understood that
a lot of folks in the West
would really struggle with
that stuff, because he
was coming from a
Buddhist background.
And he took all
that language out.
The practices were
very similar, though.
The next thing he did was
he started gathering data.
So when every new group
of folks would come in,
in the beginning,
most of them were
struggling with chronic pain.
And he was using
mindfulness and meditation
to help them deal with this.
He would gather some data.
He'd take some
baseline surveys of how
they were doing,
how their pain was,
and then they'd go through
this eight-week course,
and then he'd get
some more data.
And over time, he really amassed
an amazing body of information
about how effective mindfulness
and meditation can be.
And so now when you go
on the "Huffington Post"
and you see an article
that says, "mindfulness
cures psoriasis," it's because
they put a bunch of people
through an eight-week MBSR
course and got some data.
So I started going
to these classes.
And what I found
is that everything
I had thought I knew about
mindfulness and meditation
was completely wrong.
It is actually an incredibly
pragmatic, and clear,
and useful, and skillful way
to approach life and parenting.
And so I want to
read you-- well,
first I want to talk to you
about what my experience was.
And what I noticed is that
when I was meditating, which
I started doing at home,
much to my own surprise,
I was a lot less
reactive with my kids.
I would get less
angry with them.
I would get less frustrated.
I was more patient.
I felt less of a need to
micromanage everything
they were doing.
And I didn't really understand
that connection at first,
but I saw that it was happening.
And that red hot
glowing button I sort of
mentioned at the
beginning with the sleep,
if I was like this
glowing button that
was really super sensitive,
and bright, and red, and angry
all the time, when
I was meditating,
that button got a little smaller
and a little less sensitive.
It wasn't that it
went away completely,
but I was a lot calmer.
And I remember the first time
I really noticed a difference.
And I want to read
that to you here.
"So I still remember
the first time
I attempted to practice
mindfulness in response
to my own yelling.
I wasn't able to stop my
tantrum before it started,
but I tried a different
approach after it happened.
I went into the
kitchen, which was
my standard retreat from a
difficult parenting moment.
And instead of
scouring the cabinets
for a handful of chocolate
to shove in my mouth,
I put my hands on the counter
and took a few deep breaths.
Almost immediately, the dam
of guilty thoughts burst open.
'I'm a terrible mother.
I can't believe I
lost my temper again.
The poor girls look so scared
and I just kept yelling.'
And then for the first time,
I realized what I was doing,
and I stopped.
I just stopped.
I remembered what my
MBSR instructor had said.
'Our thoughts are just thoughts.
They're not reality, and
we don't have to treat them
as though they are.
We can choose how much to
engage with them or not.
We can let them go.'
The idea of my thoughts
were nothing more
than cars I could either
choose to get into
and cruise around in for a while
or rides I could pass up on
was a revolutionary
perspective for me.
My years of social work
training had drilled into me
the importance of our thoughts.
They were the essence of who we
are, or so I had been taught,
and they needed to be explored,
and weighed, and considered,
and understood,
and struggled with.
Well, I had done
all of that, and it
had been useful to a point.
So in that moment, I
tried something different.
I let those thoughts
go, and I tried
to implement what I was
learning about kindness,
and compassion, and curiosity.
'OK,' I thought to myself,
'you yelled your kids.
It's happened.
It's over.
What are you going to do now?
What do they need?
What do you need?
What can you do differently?'
I don't remember how
I answered myself.
Maybe I was hungry, or
stressed, or the girls
were over tired,
or getting sick.
Maybe I took some deep
breaths and offered
to read them some
books or let them watch
a show so I could have a break.
What I do remember
is how I felt.
Before when I would
freak out and then
berate myself for losing it,
I felt stuck, and helpless,
and terrible.
My mood worsen, and I
just couldn't get myself
into a better space no
matter how hard I tried.
More often than not, I would
unleash that terrible mood all
over the girls all over again.
But this time, when I
tried to pay attention
to how I was feeling, when I
tried to be nice to myself,
and interested in what
happened, my experience
was completely different.
I felt like I could breathe.
I felt like I could take a
moment to see what was going on
and get some clarity
on the situation.
I felt like I had options and
could go back to my daughters,
not only with a much
better attitude,
but with a willingness
to reconnect with them."
So you may notice in that
scenario I don't actually
remember what I did, like
what my intervention was
with my kids.
And this is an important point
about mindfulness and mindful
parenting.
It's not about what
we do specifically.
But there is an assumption,
an underlying assumption,
that when we can take a
moment, pay attention to what's
happening for
ourselves and our kids,
we're going to make a more
effective and empathic choice
in parenting, whatever
that is for us.
And this is important because
mindful parenting is often
confused with theories
like attachment parenting.
And attachment parenting is
a specific parenting theory
that talks a lot about how and
where your child should sleep,
and how you carry them,
and how you feed them.
That's not what I'm
talking about today.
I'm talking about sort of
the head space that we are in
and how changing
that perspective
can positively impact the way
we interact with our children.
So I've thrown around this
word "mindfulness" a lot,
and I want to take a minute
to actually define it.
And there's a definition
I really like,
which is sort of a hybrid of
Jon Kabat-Zinn's work and Amy
Saltzman's work.
Dr. Amy Saltzman is a
physician and a teacher,
and she's right around
the corner in Palo Alto.
And so the definition
I like is about
choosing to pay attention to
the present moment with kindness
and curiosity so we can then
choose our next behavior.
So that's a lot.
And we're going to tear
it apart a little bit.
The first part is about
choosing to pay attention,
making a choice of what
we want to focus on.
Because most of
us, I would argue,
spend most of our day
following our attention around.
It sort of gets
dragged from place
to place by our smartphone
that's glowing or buzzing,
or by a kid that's screaming,
or by a dinner that's burning,
or an urgent email that's
coming in, and all of a sudden
we have to attend to this.
And then we have
to attend to that.
And it's not often
enough that we say,
this is what I'm going
to focus on right
now, making an intentional
choice to direct our attention.
So choice is really important.
The next piece is
about paying attention.
We use these words all the
time including in parenting.
I am constantly telling my
girls, please pay attention.
But I'm not sure I ever stop
to tell them what that means.
That's a big concept.
There are some big
ideas in there.
And I never really
sat down and said,
here's what it means
to pay attention.
You face the thing you
want to pay attention to.
Maybe you look at it.
You make a choice
to listen to it.
Maybe you're smelling
it or touching it.
And when you notice
your thoughts wander,
you bring them back to the
thing you're focusing on.
I don't think I've
ever said that to them
until very recently.
And we just assume that
our kids know what it means
when we say, pay attention.
So paying attention
is the next piece,
so choosing to pay attention.
Present moment, let's
talk about this.
If you ask most people
what mindfulness
it is, they will say, it's
living in the present moment,
which sort of conjures these
scenes of like being on a beach
and frolicking in the
waves or something.
That's lovely.
It's great.
It's not what I'm
talking about here.
What I'm talking about
is making a choice
to pay attention
to what's happening
right here in the here are now.
Now in this moment,
in this room,
maybe it's the thoughts in my
head, the sound of my voice,
looking at all of you, worrying
if I'm in the camera or not,
all of these things.
There are a couple reasons
why this is important.
But the most important
one is the present moment
is where the action is.
It's the only place where
we can affect change, where
we can make a different choice.
The past already happened.
That's done.
Nothing we can do about that.
And we can spend
as much time as we
want planning for the
future, but you never
know what's going to happen.
So the present moment,
that's where the power is.
That's where the energy is.
That's where we
can do something.
The bummer is our brains
are terrible at being
in the present moment.
They don't want to do it.
They want to remember
the past, and they
want to plan for the future
and everything in between.
Here's the best explanation
I found for why that is.
A bazillion years ago,
those of us who could
remember that when Uncle
Joe wandered into the cave
and even got eaten by
a saber tooth tiger,
and then could make a plan
to not go in that cave,
we're much more likely
to survive and reproduce
than those of us who were
just sort of wandering around,
and they smell something
good coming out of the cave.
And they wander in the
cave, and they're done.
So this ability to
remember the past
and make a plan for the
future served us very well.
It still serves us
really well today,
because if you can remember that
your child has a nut allergy
and make a plan to bring a
nut-free cupcake to a birthday
party, you have avoided
both an allergic reaction
and a nasty tantrum.
So that's great.
The problem is our brains aren't
very good at turning that off.
And so we are constantly
remembering, and regretting,
and worrying, and wishing,
and hoping, and planning,
and then we miss what's
happening right in front of us.
A really common example
of this in my house
is when I ask my kids to put
their shoes on in the morning.
Any of you who have
children with feet
who wear shoes on
a regular basis
will know that this
is no simple thing.
It's so easy.
It never happens that way.
So I will say to my kids,
please go put your shoes on.
And then I go in
the kitchen, and I'm
finishing up their lunches,
getting us out the door.
And then about half the time
I yell around the corner,
put your shoes on!
Now I have not bothered
to peek around the corner
to see if they are
putting their shoes on.
We live in a tiny house.
It's not like I have to
walk over to the other wing.
I literally have
to go like that.
But I don't do it.
Because I'm already
decided based
on past experience and my
worries about the future,
they're clearly not
putting their shoes on.
But the thing is, about half
the time, they actually are.
And so what happens is
then they yell at me,
we are putting out shoes on!
And then I yell back at
them, don't yell at me!
And yes, the irony of yelling
at my kids not to yell at me
is not lost on me.
But this is where
we are sometimes.
And so in that moment, if I
had literally taken two seconds
to come back to the present
moment, to look at my children,
we could have avoided not only
a really unpleasant interaction,
but also avoided
this dynamic where
they know mom's going
to yell at them again,
so they don't have to
listen to me the first time.
And I would argue
that much of parenting
would be so much easier
if we could take the two
seconds to literally
look at our kids and tune
into them, which is
a hard thing to do.
It shouldn't be, but it is.
All right, so we're
choosing to pay attention
to the present moment with
kindness and curiosity.
The other word
that Jon Kabat-Zinn
uses for this perspective
is nonjudgmental,
because most of the
time what happens
when we tune into the
present moment is we
want it to be different.
If it's bad, we want it
to stop or get better.
If it's boring, we want it
to get more interesting.
And if it's good, we
want it to last longer.
This is what we do.
It is so rare that we
say, ah, this is great.
I'm good.
I'm just good.
Because then all of a
sudden, I'm like, actually,
I'm a little cold.
It's a little cold in here.
And I don't know.
The seats are kind of
distracting, because there's
no pattern to the red and blue
that really bothers-- you know,
the mind just goes
on and on and on.
People don't like being
alone in their thoughts.
There was actually
a recent study,
I believe it was out
of Massachusetts,
maybe it was somewhere else,
where they gave people choice.
They could either sit
alone with their thoughts,
or they could give
themselves a painful shock.
Most of the time people
wanted to shock themselves
instead of being alone
with their thoughts,
because we don't
like our thoughts.
We want them to change.
We want them to be different.
It's so challenging
for us to approach them
with kindness and curiosity.
And so, an example
of how this really
comes into play
with parenting, is
when I'm trying to teach
my daughter to ride a bike.
I have decided that
my kids have to be
able to ride a bike if they
have any chance of being
happy and successful in life.
Because clearly if
you can't ride a bike,
I might as well give
up on parenting.
There's just no point.
I don't know how.
I'm worried about this.
I'm anxious.
This is a thing.
So we take our kids
out to ride bikes.
And my daughter says,
you know, Mommy,
I really want you to
hold onto the handle bar.
Walk alongside me.
Hold onto the handlebar.
I'm like, no, she's
never going to learn how
to ride a bike if I do that.
She's got the training
wheels on there.
She'll be fine.
This is ridiculous.
I'm not doing it.
And then she's like, please
hold unto the handlebars!
No, you can ride.
You're not going to fall.
If you fall, it'll be fine.
You're like two
feet off the ground.
It's fine.
You'll be fine.
So what happens?
She flips out and
gets off the bike.
And we are no closer to
learning how to ride a bike.
But when I can get
interested, and curious,
and accepting of her
experience, and say, all right,
this is my kid is
right now-- she
needs me to hold onto the
handlebar-- we go down
the street a few times.
And then she says,
I'm good, Mom.
Take your hand off.
And we're a whole lot closer.
But that means I have to notice
and let go of all those worries
and fears swimming
around in my brain
and get interested and
accepting of her experience.
That's hard.
So the kindness and
curiosity is a big thing.
Now, it's not only about
being kind to our kids.
It's about being
kind to ourselves.
And if you remember back to my
little scene in the kitchen,
after I yelled at my kids,
the first thing I did,
my natural reaction, was to
berate myself and get angry
with myself.
So what happens when we
do that is we get stuck.
How many of you have
ever sort of really
felt horrible and ashamed or
embarrassed and then been like,
well, that was great.
I feel super energized
to go make a change now.
It doesn't happen that way.
When we're in a place of
shame and embarrassment,
we feel stuck, and we can't
make a different move.
We can't make a
different choice.
We just keep reenacting the
same dysfunctional patterns
that we always have.
When we can be kind to ourself
and forgiving and accepting,
that empowers us to do
something different.
And there's some great
research coming out
of Texas and Massachusetts
looking at self-compassion
and how that really
actually helps
people make a different
choice, make healthier choices,
sort of behavior in ways that
are more congruent with who
they want to be.
All right, so the
kindness and curiosity.
And all this leads
up to the pot of gold
at the end of the
parenting rainbow, which
is making a different
choice about how
we want to behave next.
That's the point of all this.
Because like 99% of
parenting is about how
we respond to our children.
But most of the time, we're
not responding, we're reacting.
Kid does X, I do Y. Kid
does something good,
I kiss or tell her
I'm proud of her.
I love you.
Kid does something bad,
I bite her head off.
This is not how I want
to parent my kids.
But the more we do it, the
more likely we are to do it.
Because we're creatures
of habit more,
and the more we
practice something,
the better we get at it,
even if it's something
we don't really want to
be practicing at all.
But when we can approach
the present moment
where we can make a
change, and we can do it
with kindness and curiosity
that frees us to do something
different, we're much more
likely to respond to our kids
the way we want
to, whatever that
may be for you and your family.
All right, so that's the
sort of mindfulness piece.
And so mindfulness is really
about this internal experience
of paying attention
in a specific way.
But when we're talking
about mindful parenting,
it's not just about paying
attention to ourselves.
It's about paying
attention to our kids.
We're in this relationship.
So the question is, what should
we be paying attention to
in addition to our thoughts?
Well, I would argue
that you really
need to pay attention to
what your kids are eating,
super important that they
have a healthy diet but also
a healthy relationship
with food,
so they don't end up
with an eating disorder.
Also it's really
important to make
sure your kids get
on a sports team,
because they need to know how
to interact with other people.
They need to know how to
follow directions, listen
to what the coach says,
play with other people.
But you don't want them
playing too many sports,
because they need down time.
They need quiet time to
be with their thoughts,
learn how to be bored.
Because if your
kids can't be bored,
it's going to be a big
problem because life
is so boring sometimes.
You should probably make sure
they learn a language too,
because the research on language
development in your brain,
I mean, it's just fantastic.
And we're like this
global economy.
They've got to be--
I mean, they're
just not going to
function if they
can't speak another language.
Along those lines, they
need to play an instrument.
I mean, just really-- again,
the brain development piece,
they have to be able
to play an instrument.
I mean, you guys know
where I'm going with this.
The list goes on and on.
And if you do research on
what you should be teaching
your kids, quit your jobs now.
Hire a staff.
Because you will need them.
The underlying message
behind all of these,
like your kid needs to do x
or y, is that if you do this,
they will grow up to be healthy,
productive, successful adults.
And if you don't, their
lives will be terrible.
I don't buy any of it.
We don't know.
I mean, my dad stuck
me in piano lessons.
I hated it.
I can't play.
I still don't know
what a chord is.
You never know.
Maybe you want to expose
your kids to these things
or if something works for
your kid, that's great.
But I'm going to tell you-- and
the research is very clear--
that the single most
effective choice
we can make in doing
our best to set
our kids on a path for
resiliency, happiness, success,
productivity, insert your
word of choice there,
is to have a healthy,
resilient, engaged relationship
with our kids.
That is the best chance we have.
Now, I'm not going to stand
here and tell you that if you
do that, your kid will be fine.
Parenting, and
child development,
and human development
is far too complex
to make an if/then
statement like that.
But it's the best
chance we have.
It sounds so easy,
and it's so hard.
Not only do we not get to
pick our kids temperaments--
it's not like we get to
date kids, and be like,
oh, you're too quiet.
You're too loud.
Ehh, doesn't work for me.
You poop too much.
I can't do that.
You get the kid you get.
And as I've read in
"Pinkalicious" far too
many times, you get what you
get and you don't get upset,
except for when you
get really upset.
Then you start breathing,
and it gets better.
But the other thing that's
really hard about kids
is if you think about it,
within the span of an hour,
we are their friends, their
cheerleaders, their chefs,
their jailers, their best
friends, their coaches,
their teachers,
their chauffeurs,
their disciplinarians.
It is exhausting.
And in the midst of all
this, they have the nerve
to keep growing and changing
and figuring things out,
and we can't keep up with that.
It's really hard.
Layer on top of that, we all
come from different cultures,
different religions,
different personal styles,
different family structures.
So all of these ideas that
people throw out there
at you about how to have
healthy relationship,
it's hard to know
what the answer is.
I've got a few ideas.
Of course I do, I wrote a book.
People with books have ideas.
And so the three main
chapters in my book
that are sort of the
bulk of this perspective,
the first one is about
staying connected.
This is about our
relationship with our kids.
And I think the basics of this
is that your children need
to feel safe.
And this is something that many
parenting books gloss over,
because they assume that
if you have the money
to buy a parenting book and
read a parenting book, the worst
problem you have is time out.
How do you do it?
Do you do it at all?
It's not true.
We know that millions
of American kids
don't feel safe at home.
So I'm going to
leave it at that.
But if you have
questions about safety,
if you want to talk about
it, find me on Facebook.
We'll talk about it.
Safe, seen-- our kids
need to feel seen by us.
They need to know that we know
who they are, and we love them
and accept them for it.
This is the work of a
lifetime, and most of us
will never get there.
But that doesn't
mean we stop trying.
Safe, seen, soothed-- OK,
I'm running through these,
I know I am.
But there's more in the book,
and we can talk about it later.
Soothe-- our kids need to know
how to manage big emotions.
Most of us don't know how to
manage big emotions, which
is why we drink too much.
We eat too much.
We shop too much.
We gamble too much.
We yell too much.
So to the extent
that we can start
teaching our kids about this
right now, that's a big deal.
And I have some ideas in the
book about how to do that.
And the last one is supported.
And when I talk about
supporting our kids,
I mean supporting them
as opposed to controlling
them or micromanaging them.
Again, this is a very
hard thing to do.
Because when your kid spills the
beads across the wooden floor
for the eighth time in a
day, all you want to do
is grab the necklace and
say, I'll make it for you.
But that's not what they need.
So safe, seen, soothed,
and supported--
I like my little s's.
It helps you remember things.
So the first part of this
mindful parenting business
is about staying
connected to our kids.
But as I've said time
and again, it's hard.
So we need to stay grounded.
We need to take
care of ourselves.
Most parenting books gloss
over this with the sleep
when the baby sleeps.
That's the self-care
piece they give you.
So if your kid's not
a baby, I'm sorry.
We have no advice for you.
Just give it up.
Also, if your kid sleeps
in the car like mine did,
and you're driving, and you
cannot sleep when the baby
sleeps, you're probably screwed.
No, no, I go into this
in a lot more detail.
And what I talk about in
this is self-awareness,
getting to know ourselves
and understanding ourselves.
And one of the things I
learned about myself when
I became a parent is I need
a huge amount of alone time
and downtime during a
day in order to be able
interact kindly
with my children.
And so I started writing,
because I needed to be alone.
And now I can be in a much
better place with my kids.
That's an example of the
self-awareness piece.
Self-compassion
we've talked about.
Self-care-- here's
the one thing I'm
going to say about self-care.
In a lot of places
in this country,
self-care gets confused
with self-improvement.
So when you have a
chunk of free time,
you are out training
for marathon.
You're making a
quilt for your child.
You are making cupcakes.
You're learning a new skill.
Now, if those things nourish and
rejuvenate you, that's great.
Go do them.
But if you're doing them out
of a sense of compulsion,
and you'd rather actually
be staring at the wall,
go stare at the wall.
Take care of yourself.
You wouldn't say to
your kid if they're
feeling sick and
exhausted, quick,
let's go do some math homework!
That will make you
feel so much better.
You'd say, why don't
you lay on the couch,
and I'll bring you a blanket
and your favorite toy,
and I'll read you a story.
Well, what if we did that for
ourselves when we're worn out.
Go lay on the couch.
Wrap yourself in a blanket.
Read a good book,
whatever it is for you.
So we really need to reexamine
our definition of self-care.
And finally, again, support--
we can't do this alone.
It is not possible to
raise a child alone.
And yet, so many mothers in
my generation where this as
like a badge of pride.
Oh, my kid was
puking all weekend,
and my husband was out of town.
But it's fine.
I got it.
It's like, no.
Let your friend
bring you some soup.
Because then they know
that when they need that,
you're going to do it for them.
And one of the things
that happens with support
is most of us go into
parenthood assuming
that all the friendships and
relationships we had before
are going to support us
after we become a parent.
And it's not necessarily true.
Relationships change.
And then all of a sudden,
the people in your life,
it's like a random coworker,
or this person on your street,
maybe it's the
pediatrician you happen
to get assigned to
at the practice--
and we just run with it
because we're too tired
and overwhelmed
to make a change.
But we need to make a conscious
choice and think about,
are the people in my life
who are supporting me
actually supporting me?
And do I need to find a
parenting support group?
Do I need to seek out
some new friendships?
What do I need to do?
All right, so if staying
connected with our kids
and staying grounded are two
sides of a scale that we're
constantly trying
to get balanced
but it never quite
works, staying present,
which is my last big chapter,
is the solid grounding
keeps that scale upright.
This is the mindfulness piece.
It is crucial to all of this.
None of it works
without the mindfulness.
Because let's say
you decide you're
going to take your kids to
the aquarium for the day.
You're going to
have this great day.
connect with them.
And then you spend
the whole time
stressing about a fight
you had with your partner,
how you're going to pay
the rent this month.
You're going to come
out of it, and your kids
aren't going to feel any
more connected to you.
You're not going to feel
any more connected to them.
You're just going
to be stressed out.
So don't even waste the
money on the aquarium
in the first place.
Just stay home and
stress out there.
It's a lot cheaper.
And same thing with
your staying grounded,
your self-care-- in
my town, everybody
goes to get pedicures.
This is like the thing you do.
I finally discovered
after like five pedicures
that I don't like
strangers touching my feet.
And I was like, oh,
maybe I won't do that.
But I would go to
these pedicures,
and I'd be on my phone,
making my to-do list
for all the things I
was going to get done as
soon as the pedicure was over.
And then I'd be like, oh,
the birthday party, what
are we going to do about that?
And I haven't really
planned summer camp
and all of these things.
And then I'd come
out there as wired
and wound up as when I went in.
I didn't feel any better.
And then I had the
stranger touching my feet.
It was like a total
waste of time.
So when you can be in
the present moment,
even if it's for like two
minutes several times a day,
it's going relax you, help
you feel more calm, soothed,
controlled, on top of things.
Here's the hard part about
mindfulness-- I can't give you
a pill for this.
There's no like perfect
secret trick, like do this
and it'll be done.
You'll be like this
mindful awesome person.
And mindfulness is
actually very easy to do.
It's very hard to
remember to do.
So the trick with
staying present
is to try to create a
structure in your life
that's going to make it easier
for you to remember to do this,
which is why when you go
away on a meditation retreat,
it's like this
beautiful building.
And it's very
uncluttered and clean.
And there's like the
Buddha smiling at you.
There's always a field.
They always find a
beautiful field to stare at.
Because they know
that you're going
to have an easier,
better time at this
retreat if you're not staring
at a pile of dirty laundry
the whole time.
But most of us can't go away
on retreat all the time.
This is not a possibility.
So what can we do in our lives?
We can slow down.
And there's no trick
to slowing down.
You just have to
decide it's something
you want to do, and see if you
can add in five minutes here,
five minutes there, or
decide it doesn't really--
you're not going to fight with
your kid over their clothes,
because it's not worth the time.
And if they really want
to wear pajamas to school,
they're going to wear pajamas
to school, whatever it is.
But are there ways
that you can slow down?
Because one of the things
I've noticed about myself
as a parent is I just start
hurrying even when I'm no tin
a rush.
It's like, come on.
Let's go.
And we have plenty of time.
Why am I doing that?
I have no idea.
And then I have to
be like, slow down.
Simplifying your life
makes it much easier
to slow down and be mindful.
And the best example
I have is sippy cups.
These are going to
the death of me.
For a long time, we had
like eight different types
of sippy cups.
And of course, my girls are
like I want the Lalaloopsy.
I want the Hello Kitty.
And the Lalaloopsy
takes a straw.
And the Hello Kitty
needs a valve.
And I'm raahh,
freaking out, because I
can't find the right
top for the right cup.
And then one day-- it
took me like three years
to get to this stroke of
brilliance-- I was like no.
We're going to have one kind of
sippy cup with one kind of top.
And you get what you get.
And then my girls know it's
Hello Kitty or nothing.
That's not so bad.
She's cute.
So all of a sudden, that whole
piece of stress wasn't there.
So simplifying is a great idea.
Savoring-- this is a big word
in the mindfulness world.
What does this mean?
It means being fully in the
moment with all of our senses
and truly appreciating it.
Now what happens when there's
a cute moment for most of us?
We pull out our phones, because
we've got take a picture of it,
because it's so cute.
We've got to capture it.
And then you look at it, and
the colors aren't quite right.
OK, I'm going to
put it on Instagram.
I'm going to put a filter
on it, because that's
going to look really good.
And then you send
it over to Facebook.
And then you're on Facebook.
And oh my gosh!
My friend had a baby.
That's adorable.
And then you're like
clicking through.
And it's like the dancing cats.
And I'm a sucker
for dancing cats,
so I have to watch that video.
And then I've totally
missed the moment.
It is gone because I had
to take a picture of it.
And so when I think
about savoring,
I think about taking a
picture with my mind.
And the idea, the memory I
have of this is one morning,
I'm sitting there
drinking my coffee.
I look over at my kids,
and they're playing
with stickers on the couch.
And my first thought was
like, (FRANTICALLY) oh my god!
They got stickers on the couch.
They're going to get the
stickers all over the couch!
I'm not going to get the
stickers off the couch!
And then I thought
about it for a minute.
It's a shitty IKEA coach.
What do I care?
We can change the slip cover.
It's like $50.
But nonetheless, I
was like, OK, I'm
going to let them play
with the stickers.
And then I just sat there.
And I was like, I have
a hot cup of coffee.
The sun is shining
in the window.
My kids are sharing
their stickers.
None of the stickers have been
torn, so nobody's flipping out.
It was like a little
commercial for a happy family.
And I just sat there
and noticed it.
And it was lovely.
And three years later,
I remember that moment.
And we've had a million
of those moments
that I don't remember because
I rushed through them.
That's what savoring
is all right.
So we have slowing down,
simplifying, savoring,
and my favorite--
this is my S word.
I'm sure somebody
else came up with it,
but I did to-- single-tasking.
So we are a nation
of multitaskers.
How many job descriptions have
we all read where it's like,
multitasking a plus!
This is a good thing.
OK, so what we know
from the research
is we are actually not
capable of multitasking.
The word they use this
task switching now.
So what that means is
we're doing one thing,
and then we're like
watching "Law & Order,"
and then I'm
cutting the carrots.
And so I'm like, what
happened to the murdered guy?
And then I'm going
to cut the carrots.
And then my kid comes in.
And she's flipping out, so
I'm going to fix that problem.
And then I'm going
to cut the carrots.
And I'm so proud of
myself, because I'm
this super productive person
who can do all these things.
And then I cut my finger.
And then the carrots
are on the floor,
and I never hear the end of
the "Law & Order" episode,
and it's not on Netflix
so I can't see it.
And my kid's problem
never gets resolved.
It didn't actually work, but
I'm also multitasking-- no.
We can't do it.
What we know is that our
brains jump back and forth.
We never focus on
one thing fully.
And then we need a
few seconds in between
to readjust to the new thing,
so it's super ineffective.
And it's super inefficient.
And it's really not that
possible to be mindful
when you're multitasking.
So trying to do one thing
at a time is a great idea.
So we have staying connected
to our kids, staying grounded,
and staying present.
And whenever I give this talk,
the question I always get
is, how do I get started?
And there are a bunch of
different ways, recommendations
I have.
Because me standing up
here and saying to you,
just go be mindful,
it's cool, just do it,
is kind of like
saying to your kid,
just go out on that soccer field
during that championship game,
kick the winning goal
when you have never
practiced a day in your life.
And that's what I did
to myself that day
when I sat down and Googled,
how do I stop yelling?
Trying to be mindful when
your kid is exploding right
in front of you, making a
serious behavioral change
in your own experience
during a time of crisis,
is not possible if you haven't
been practicing all along.
So the trick with
mindfulness is you've
got to start when it's easy.
Because as Karen Maezen Miller,
who is an amazing Zen Buddhist
priest and a mindfulness
teacher and a mother, says,
life is suffering enough.
Don't make it worse with
your mindfulness practice.
I'm paraphrasing her.
So start when it's easy.
So what I like to do, there
are two different things.
One is my informal
mindfulness practice.
I pick a couple times
during the day when
I'm doing something
I enjoy, that I
know I'm going to
be doing every day,
and I make a point to
pay attention to it.
So this is when
I'm in the shower,
because what happens
when I'm in the shower is
I get to the end of the
shower, my hair is wet.
I have no idea if I
washed it, not a clue.
So I've started
paying attention.
And what I find is
that taking a shower
is this awesome experience.
I have hot water.
That's a great thing.
And I can get clean
and not stink.
This is also a very great thing.
So I pay attention to my shower.
And then I pay attention
to reading to my kids.
We do it every night.
Because the mind is an
amazing, amazing thing.
I could sit there
next to my kids,
read the entire storybook to
them, get to the end of it,
and I have no idea what
happened, not a clue.
How my mind can read the
words, say them out loud,
and not hear a single
one of them is beyond me.
But it does.
It happens all the time.
So I've noticed that when
I actually pay attention
to the storybook, children's
literature today is amazing.
The pictures are fantastic.
The stories are good.
And if they're not,
the book disappears.
And when I'm sitting there with
my kids on either side of me,
like snuggled up, it's
this beautiful moment.
And we all feel a little calmer,
and a little more connected,
and a little happier at the end.
So if you can find a couple
of practices every day,
that's something you're going
to do every day that you
enjoy, pay attention to it.
Within about 30 seconds,
your mind is going to wander.
And when you notice
your mind wandering--
that's what Sharon Salzberg
calls the magic moment,
because it's the
moment you can choose
to do something different.
You choose to let go of that
thought, whatever it is,
come back to your experience.
The other one is
formal meditation.
If informal mindfulness, the
paying attention in the shower,
is like walking up the stairs
to get a little more exercise
or parking on the other
side of the parking lot,
formal meditation is
like going to the gym.
We're practicing
paying attention.
We're practicing being
bored and being OK with it.
Because guess what?
Parenting is boring
a lot, for any you
who have ever played Chutes
and Ladders-- boring, right?
So we're practicing
getting bored, being bored,
and being OK with it.
We're practicing noticing
big emotions come across us
and being OK with
those, letting them go.
We're practicing not getting
hijacked by our own thoughts.
So there are four
traditional ways
you can do this-- standing
up, sitting down, laying
down, or walking.
If I lay down to meditate, I
fell asleep and I miss pick up.
Yes, that happened once.
I am not hardcore
enough to stand up.
So I usually sit down.
And when I just can't
sit still, I walk.
And what I do is
I find my breath.
I notice it.
And if you all do this
right now, just notice.
Where do you feel
your breath the most?
Is it at the tip of your nose?
Is it coming into your mouth?
Is it your chest?
Is it your belly?
And then just keep noticing it.
You don't have to change it.
You don't have to count your
breaths or breathe deeply.
You just notice.
And if you're anything like most
of us, within about a breath,
your mind will wander.
And then you notice
your mind wandering,
and you come back
to your breath.
And you do it again,
and again, and again.
And what most people say is,
I'm a terrible meditator,
because I can't keep
my mind on my breath.
It's not about how many
breaths you can keep it for.
It's about how often you can
notice that your mind has
wandered and bring it back.
When you're lifting
weights, you don't
expect to stand
there for 20 minutes
holding weights up in the air.
You just keep lifting.
With meditating, you just
keep breathing and noticing.
And over time, this
will make it easier
for you to not be such a big
red hot button in reaction
to your kids.
And even if you feel like
your meditation session was
terrible, hang in there.
See what happens in
the heat of the moment.
It makes a difference.
So those are my thoughts
on mindfulness and mindful
parenting.
It looks like we have a few
minutes for questions, which
I would be happy to answer.
And thank you all for your
time and your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: What you said is
more about managing yourself
than managing your kids.
CARLA NAUMBURG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Which is quite
insightful, and I love it.
But is there any research
showing the other way,
that is, can kids be managed?
Can kids be-- like,
[INAUDIBLE] occasions
you said that we all
experience, that I just
felt the kids were unreasonable,
or not listening, or not doing
what they should do, or having
emotion, acting up, not doing
what they're supposed to do.
And also, the most frustrating
thing is it's unreasonable.
You don't know why they don't
do what they're supposed to do.
So is there any research
showing that there's also
a managing the kids side?
CARLA NAUMBURG: So you're
asking about the efficacy
of mindfulness with children?
Is that kind of what
we're looking at?
AUDIENCE: Not-- whatever
methodology, but meaning
essentially training the
kids or educating the kids
to be more cooperative.
CARLA NAUMBURG: That's
the golden question,
if I had the answer to that--
AUDIENCE: So if they
don't listen, other
than I take a deep
breath, I manage myself,
is there any technique or any
fact at all that [INAUDIBLE].
CARLA NAUMBURG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I keep on
thinking, when I was a kid,
I always listened
to my parents--
the discipline or, of course,
a different culture, that is,
whether any discipline, any
control of kids would be--
CARLA NAUMBURG: So questions
about behavior management.
AUDIENCE: Maybe that's
just wishful thinking.
Maybe you can't.
CARLA NAUMBURG: No, I
think there are some ideas.
First of all, I don't want
us to underestimate the power
of managing ourselves.
And they did a really
interesting study
with some folks where
they took some parents who
identified their children's
having behavioral problems,
whatever that is.
And they put the parents through
the eight-week MBSR course.
This is not a parenting course.
They did not talk
about parenting.
They taught the parents to
meditate, practice mindfulness.
And what they found
coming back a year later
is that those parents
who stuck with it
reported that their kid's
behavior was significantly
improved.
So let's not underestimate that.
Having said that, behavior
management is a huge question.
And there are as many
experts with opinions
as there are children
with problems or children
who are normal and
don't have problems
and still-- there's
a whole range.
And what I would
say is, this is not
going to be the answer
you want to hear.
It depends on your family.
It depends on your child.
It depends on who
the parents are,
who the teachers are, whoever's
involved, and what works,
and what you're
comfortable with.
Some people are
comfortable with time outs,
and that's effective.
And some people just aren't.
Some people are comfortable
with redirection,
and some people feel like
that's not stern enough.
I mean, there's a
range of options.
So I think that's sort
of a bigger question.
But there are certainly a lot
of people with a lot of opinions
about that one.
But thank you.
AUDIENCE: As a
prospective parent,
what would be the things
that you think, other
than preparing and practicing
mindfulness and looking
into things like your
books, your talks,
all those kind of
stuff, are there
any other avenues that are
less specific to mindfulness
that you'd recommend
looking into?
CARLA NAUMBURG: Getting
ready to have a kid?
Yes.
I would suggest you spend time
with people who have children.
And the thing is, that's
not really what you actually
want to do when you're
getting ready to have a kid,
because you want to go out
and live this child-free life,
which you should also do.
I would suggest you spend
a lot of time trying
to let go of the illusion
of control, which is so
easy to say and so hard to do.
Here's the tricky thing--
looking back, I'm like,
oh, I wish I had known this.
I wish somebody had told me
all of these things about how
I would feel, and what
I need to be doing,
and the fact that kids will
projectile vomit everywhere
all the time.
Like, I wish somebody
had said to me,
you need to prepare yourself
to manage a lot of vomit.
And the thing is,
I'm sure they did.
And I said, oh yeah, I'm good.
I've got little
brothers and sisters.
I've got cousins.
I am good.
I'm good with this.
And it's a thing
that everybody has
to go through, because
every child is different.
Here's what I would say--
get yourself a good support
network.
Find the people who are
going to stick by you.
And it's a little hard to
know, because you never
know how people are going
to react when they become
a grandparent, or
an aunt and uncle,
or when their best
friend has a kid
and they don't have a kid yet.
You never really know, but
just like the support network.
And then the other thing,
which I just heard yesterday
at a talk I did, is if you
get paternity leave, which
I think here at Google they
have a very generous paternity
leave, take it.
Take all of it.
Take every last day
of it-- not only
because your wife, or spouse,
or parenting partner, whoever,
will love you and it will
help your marriage immensely.
But the research
down the road on how
it's going to impact your
involvement in your child's
life and the equity in
the relationship in terms
of child care is astounding.
So take your paternity leave.
And then just be prepared to
be more tired than you've ever
been in your life and
know it'll get better.
Does anybody else--
I'm sure there
are parents in the room--
have any other advice?
Because I know I'm
missing something.
My sister's here.
She's like, yeah.
I could a lot of advice.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
That was an excellent talk.
I'm actually in complete
agreement with everything
you said.
CARLA NAUMBURG: Oh, thanks.
AUDIENCE: But implementing
some things I find challenging.
So, for example, you mentioned
taking care of yourself, which
you think is important.
But with the two young kids,
and the heavy work schedules,
and their individual
schedules, do
you have any helpful tips
on how you can find time
to take care of yourself?
CARLA NAUMBURG: Yes, I do
have some helpful tips.
This is a great question.
It's one that many
of us struggle with.
One, and this is, I
think, more of an issue
with moms than dads, is we
have to let go the guilt
about taking care of ourselves.
We see it as like super
indulgent, and it's not.
It's basic self-care like
breathing and eating.
And we wouldn't say, it's cool.
I'm taking care of a kid.
I'm just not going to eat
for the next three months.
So don't do that
with your self-care.
The other thing I
would say is we often
assume that self-care
takes hours at a time.
It's like, I need an
afternoon to go for a hike,
or run, or play golf,
or whatever it is.
Often it's not that.
It's 10 minutes.
It's half an hour
here and there.
I will frequently arrive
at pick up for my girls
10 minutes early and sit
in the car and breathe.
And that's all I
can get in a day,
and it makes a huge
difference, as opposed
to when I'm like
checking my emails,
and thinking about my to-do
list, and then I run in.
And all of a sudden,
it feels like my kids
are an intrusion on
my life, because I'm
right in the middle of
trying to do something.
So just giving yourself a
little time to sort of switch,
and then also figuring
out what matters for you
in terms of self-care.
Like everybody's got advice.
You have to be doing yoga.
You have to be eating kale.
I hate kale.
I don't want to eat kale.
But I need to be eating
kale to take care of myself.
Like, there's a laundry
list a mile long
of what people say
you should be doing.
And figuring out what actually
works for you is important.
So for me, it's sleep and
really long walks alone,
which I have to make time for.
And I know I'm not as productive
in my professional life
because I go for
a 45 minute long
walk most days of the week.
I'm lucky to have
the flexibility.
But I know I'm also
less crazy with my kids.
And that's a trade off
I can, I'm lucky enough,
and I'm willing to make.
My vet, he goes and spends
an hour on the trapeze
every Friday.
This is like my hell on earth.
This sounds horrible.
But it's what lets him
parent effectively.
So I think taking some
time to figure out
what is it that you need.
And if you can't
do it for an hour,
can you do it for 10 minutes?
But again, and the thing about
little kids is, they get older,
and it gets better.
So now my kids are almost
five and 6 and 1/2.
And I can say, Mommy's
going to go meditate
in the other room
for 20 minutes.
Please, please leave me alone.
And I would say four out
of 10 times, they do it.
And four out of 10 is
so much better than zero
out of 10, which is
where I was for years.
So it gets better, I promise.
AUDIENCE: You are talking about
just different strategies,
like jumping jacks, screaming
into the toilet, walks,
deep breaths, pushing the wall--
is there anything else that you
can recommend for when
we're in the moment
and the tantrum is right there?
CARLA NAUMBURG: Yes.
There are many, many strategies.
And you can find them online.
Literally just sit down
and Google, how do I
stop yelling at my kids.
But the trick is,
you have to notice
that it's about to happen.
And for some of us, that
noticing is in our bodies.
It's like they get tense.
Our stomach gets all knotted up.
The shoulders go
up, whatever it is.
Or it's the thoughts,
like, oh my god.
I'm so pissed off.
This is horrible.
It has to end, whatever it is.
But if you don't
notice it, you're
not going to make the change.
And if you don't practice
noticing in the easy moments,
you're not going to be able
to notice in the hard moments.
So I have to come
back and say, again,
the best thing you can do is
start some sort of meditation
and mindfulness.
Because I don't
want to say to you,
just go notice when
you're about to explode,
because that is setting
you up for failure,
just like I did for myself.
So really, if you could start
practicing, even five minutes
of meditation a
day, you're going
to get so much--
like you're literally
strengthening those neural
pathways in your brain.
It's going to get
so much better.
AUDIENCE: Any advice on
teaching children mindfulness
or doing mindfulness
activities together with them?
CARLA NAUMBURG: That's
fabulous, advice on teaching
children mindfulness.
I have a book coming out about
this at the end of December.
Thank you so much for that.
It's called "Ready,
Set, Breathe."
It's going to be published
by New Harbinger.
And what I would say
is the first step
to teaching kids mindfulness
is to practice it yourself
and talk to them about it.
They will get curious.
There are also many excellent
picture books for kids.
So if you go on
Amazon and just Google
"mindfulness, meditation,
picture book, kids," whatever
it is, you will find
great books that
will start to introduce
the concept to kids.
So those are where
I would start.
But find me on Facebook.
Shoot me an email, and I can
send you some more stuff.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you so much.
CARLA NAUMBURG: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]